(upbeat electronic music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Rhett.
- And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're asking the question
do we like getting recognized in public?
- Mm, but before we get
into that discussion,
we wanna let you know
that we are going on tour
and we're gonna announce all the dates
for the rest of--
- It was weird,
the way you said tour.
- 2019.
I wanna make it clear--
- Tour.
- That this is it, guys.
These are the only dates for 2019.
This may be the only
dates for some time, okay,
we don't know if we're
gonna be going out again
in 2020, we don't know.
So this might be your
last chance definitely
to see this show, a night
of music and comedy.
We're gonna be in Las Vegas on June 21st,
Salt Lake City on June 22nd,
Denver on June 23rd,
Milwaukee on the 25th,
Indianapolis on the 26th,
Detroit on the 27th,
Omaha on the 29th,
and Minneapolis on the 30th.
So that's coming up, that's
coming up end of June.
- All right and then I got some fall dates
starting September 4th.
We're gonna be on Houston, we're
gonna be on Houston, Texas.
- [Rhett] Yeah we are coming on Houston.
- September 4th, New
Orleans September 5th,
Birmingham, Alabama September 6th,
Jacksonville, Florida September 7th,
Tampa, Florida September 8th.
Then skipping down to the end of November.
Albuquerque, New Mexico, November 20th,
Phoenix 21st, Sacramento,
California November 22nd,
and Valley Center, California--
- The center of the valley.
- Harrah's Resort
on November 23rd.
RhettAndLinkLive.com, get your tickets.
I wanna get an update, I've
kinda gotten the update,
I want you to give the listener an update
on your mimic diet thing
'cause anytime you do
what I'll call an experiment on yourself,
I don't know how you would describe it.
- I would describe it
as a failed experiment.
- Oh okay especially if it's a failure,
I wanna hear about it.
I want them to hear about it.
I wanna hear about it twice,
I'll put it to you that way. (chuckles)
- Okay, quick refresh,
it was a diet designed
by a professor
who got together with the people
at the Anti-Aging Institute
or something that's
named something like that
and created a diet that tricks your body
into thinking that it's fasting
so you get the benefits,
the physiological benefits of fasting
without going on completely nothing.
But for me, for a big man like me--
- What happened?
- I'm just adding to
the big man montage.
700 calories is not a lot
so I lost nine pounds,
which not hard to do when
you're as big as I am,
but I actually had the benefit of--
- How much did you weigh?
- I was probably like 215 when I started.
- Okay.
- And the reason I know
exactly how much I lost
and the composition of
what I lost is because
I did that thing they
have at my gym called
the Mbody where you get up
there and you hold the thing
and it gives a very
specific analysis of your,
I trust that it's accurate.
- There's one at my gym too.
You stand on the thing barefoot
and then you hold these
things on your thumbs
and you hold your arms out like that.
- Yeah.
- And you don't move.
- And then it gives you
like this is how much muscle
you have in your right
arm, in your left arm.
And then it gives you
your BMI and all that.
So before,
it just happened that I did
it right before and after
and we were looking at it
and my trainer was like,
you lost nine pounds,
and then she was like,
six pounds of water. (chuckles)
- Dang.
That doesn't sound like
the right thing to lose.
- Two pounds of muscle.
- Oh, 'kay.
- And one pound of fat.
- Yeah.
- So mission not accomplished.
- Not good.
- I lost more of what I want,
less of what I don't want,
and I want water.
- Oh yeah.
- It wasn't that I had dehydrated myself,
it was something about the
fact that your nutrients enable
water intake into your
muscles or whatever,
but the thing that I also notices is that
I have all kinds of issues with my back,
all up and down the spine
and muscle stuff that happens
because of weird things in my discs
and all that got exacerbated to the point
that it was tightening up,
because your body needs
stuff, it needs nutrients,
especially if you're
kinda borderline about
to go into a muscle spasm at any moment
and so, but after a week
of just regular eating,
everything is back to normal.
- You gained nine pounds?
- Well I haven't done that,
I'm just saying that I feel
good again, my back is good.
- Are you still doing
intermittent fasting?
- Yeah I'm still doing that.
- Because that is not a diet, that is a--
- It's a lifestyle.
- Well some people are like,
but don't promote diets,
especially ones that don't work.
- Yeah and the fasting thing--
- I was reading that.
- The fasting wasn't a diet,
it was a fasting period
for very specific reasons
and it wasn't so I could lose weight,
that wasn't why I was doing it.
I'm doing it because I
wanted to have something
I could go back to on a quarterly basis
if it did have good
results in those numbers
then I'd do it again but--
- So you do recommend it.
- Yeah highly.
- And use code ear to lose
nine pounds of the wrong stuff.
- Yeah, you could--
- We shouldn't be throwing our coupon code
for like bump things.
- If you wanna lose
one pound of fat and eight
pounds of muscle and water.
(Link chuckles)
- Oh gosh.
- You got too much water and muscles.
- Don't use code--
- You know who you are.
(Link chuckles)
- Too much muscle and water.
Yeah so we're gonna, well
first of all, I got a cold.
I'm three days into this thing.
I actually--
- Don't breathe on me.
- It's a pet peeve of mine--
- This is a bad time
to get a cold, this is a
tough time to get a cold.
- What do you mean?
- Transitioning from spring to summer,
it's just, it makes you
feel like you're out
of sync with nature.
- I'm gonna be good in about two days
'cause I've been doing this
thing called the mimic diet.
Mimic fasting diet.
- So that's different than
the fasting mimicking diet.
- Oh.
- It must be different.
Maybe you'll gain muscle now.
- Except trying to nap.
It's a pet peeve of mine for
podcasters to go on and on
about how their voice is
different and apologizing
about how they're sick.
- I think it's good to acknowledge though.
- I just wanna acknowledge it.
Got some Kleenex down here.
But yeah we're gonna talk
about a question we get often,
I think when we're being
recognized, at least I know I do,
is do you get recognized often?
And I think the implied
follow-up question is
how do you feel about that
or this as it's happening?
- And I also think that people wanna know
if they are the, like a
special source of something
like maybe he doesn't
get recognized that often
and I've made his week.
- So I wanna get into that
but something happened to me
that I wanted, I've been
saving this story to share
with you and you, and you too Jacob.
I was pointing at the
camera which represents
one loyal listener but then you know--
- But also Jacob.
- Out of the corner of
his eye he saw me point.
Now I am pointing at you.
That's what it feels like
for me to point at you.
Incidentally, pointing
is a part of this story.
- Oh gosh.
This is not good.
- It's fine.
This happened in the context
of when we were taking care
of my father-in-law Lewis. (chuckles)
At the hospital and I took
a break and I came home
and I was exhausted and
I was gonna take a nap
but then I was like you know what,
it would be therapeutic
for me to walk the dog
and I'm gonna make Lily come with me,
so come along so I can
spend some time with her
'cause I just wasn't
seeing the kids as much
in that phase of caring
for him in the hospital.
- Right.
- So we went out
for a walk and
we're walking down the street
and I remembered the doggy bags.
A lot of times I don't
remember the doggy bags
and I'm glad I did because--
- Hold on when you don't, what do you do?
- I'll use, if Jade poops, I'll use--
- A leaf?
- I'll find a big leaf
and use it as a glove and
then I'll just throw it all
into the woods.
- What woods?
- Well the woods on my walk, like trees.
Not someone's front yard.
- There's not a lot of
woods where we're out here
so you're throwing it onto
somebody's property, man.
- I mean there are trees
and little wooded areas.
Unmowed areas of people's yard.
- (chuckles) Okay, yeah, people's yards.
(Link laughing)
Okay but the wooded
parts of people's yards
that they never go into.
- The thing about Jade is she likes to,
we'll be walking, all of
a sudden I'll realize,
ope, the leash is getting
caught and I'll look back there
and she's poppin' a squat
in the middle of the street.
- Yeah, Barbara does the same thing.
- Like she doesn't go to the
grass in somebody's yard.
She's very respectful of that.
She goes to the, not even
on the lane of the street
where she's walking, like on the edge.
She'll go to the middle
of the road and like--
- Yeah she wants people to know.
- I wanna have a wide berth as I--
- That's funny 'cause Barbara--
- Give birth.
- Does the same thing.
- To this poop.
- And I always thought
that that was, I was
doing something wrong.
Like she's stupid, she doesn't understand.
We never told her that
she shouldn't do that.
- That yeah, it feels more
natural to do it on the grass
or some dirt.
- It's easier to clean up
when it's on the concrete.
- I like to throw some
dirt or some leaves on it
before I pick it up so I do
not like it being on the dirt.
I don't like just grabbing--
- You're like Mr. Leon
throwing sawdust on vomit.
- Yeah he was the janitor at
our Buies Creek Elementary.
- May he rest in peace.
- Great man.
So anyway, she pops a squat
in the middle of the street
and I'm like, then I'm
cleaning it up with the bag.
You put your hand, you
know how to do this,
you put your hand in the
bag, then you grab it
and you turn it around in your hand
but it still is really
bothersome to me, it's like--
- So warm.
- It's so warm and I feel like
it's coming through this bag in some way.
And that's why I like to--
- Well it probably is
a little bit.
- Nature's sawdust, whatever I can find,
I try to let that--
- Some mulch from
somebody's yard. (chuckles)
- Yeah yeah a little bit of mulch.
- Yeah they don't need this.
- Yeah.
Have you seen me do this?
- The way, the objects in
your story as if you're
on a hike in Yosemite but
really you're in the suburbs
of Los Angeles where there's no woods.
It's just trees in
people's yard and the mulch
that they have so carefully arranged.
And you're using it--
- They don't miss
a little bit.
- As sawdust.
- So then I'm carrying this bag around
and we turn the corner and
we're going up the street
and I will say at this point,
because this is the point
in the street where it usually happens,
there's this car that's
typically parked there
that has a vanity license plate.
You know me and my Bumper Stumpers,
I always notice the vanity license plates
and there's a license
plate that said Mr. Noodle.
- Oh.
- Which,
for those of you who don't know,
Mr. Noodle is a live action
mime character in Elmo's World,
the Sesame Street series,
and he was kinda like
a clown without makeup.
He would do clownish things
and then Mr. Noodle had
a brother Mr. Noodle
and Elmo would voiceover this whole,
you know Mr. Noodle, right?
- Never watched it.
- Lily was really into Elmo,
I think Lincoln was too.
- I saw the controversy
come and never let my kids,
I just sensed it, never let 'em watch it.
- Oh.
I separate the man from the puppet.
- That's a difficult thing to
do when his hand is in there.
(Link chuckles)
(both chuckling)
Pretty much becomes a dead Elmo
when you take him out of the--
(Link chuckling)
- Okay good point, I
have no response to that.
I'm not even gonna tell my story now.
So I will clarify that
there are no controversies
that I know of associated with Mr. Noodle
or his brother Mr. Noodle.
- Even though with that name
you would think there would be.
- Right.
(both laughing)
- If anybody's problematic,
it's probably Mr. Noodle.
- Right.
Mr. Noodle's brother
Mr. Noodle was played by
the guy from Evening Shade who--
- Oh I loved that.
- Who was also in
The Green Mile but I
can't be more specific
about what his name is but anyway--
- Mustache.
- So this license plate
Mr. Noodle and then sometimes
but on a rare occasion,
I'll see another car and it says,
the license plate said Dr. Noodle.
I'm like oh there's a family of Noodles
that live around here.
- What?
- And so for like two years,
I've seen these vanity license plates,
and so it's just a part of my life.
And sometimes we'll point it out,
there's Mr. Noodle's parked there again.
That's just a little background.
So we're walking and now
I've got this poop bag
in my hand and Lily and I are walking.
I'm catching her up on the
situation at the hospital
and everything, we're
having a great conversation,
but I'm bothered by the fact
that I haven't even completed
30% of this dog walk and I'm
already holding poop in a bag.
I do not like being that guy.
I judge heavily the people
I see walking their dog
with a big sack of poop in their hand.
- Right, you gotta offload that.
- What a loser, but I also,
I hate seeing poop bags
just laying around.
We are humans, you know.
We're at a point on the
food chain where we need
to love our earth to
the point where we can't
just throw plastic poop bags
down just because of pride.
- You see people throw
plastic poop bags down?
- I see them laying down, I see evidence
that they've been left places.
Like when you go on hikes around LA,
there's people who will
drop their poop bag,
and you know what they're thinking?
They're thinking, I hate
walking around with a poop bag.
When I come back down the
trail, I'll pick it up
and throw it away.
No, you don't.
- And then when they see it,
they're like, well, that
could be anybody's poop bag.
- It's not mine.
Oh yeah you conveniently forget about it.
I don't wanna be that guy so
I'm in a catch 22 situation,
so I tell Lily, I'm like, Lily.
When I spot a trash can,
you're gonna get rid of this thing.
Now the trash had come
recently so it wasn't like
everyone's trash cans were out.
- But there are the stragglers.
- There's some stragglers
and you're looking for that.
- One out of 10.
- So I'm like we're
looking for stragglers.
We round this corner and go
down this other dead end street.
I'm talking to her like
this and she's looking at me
like, you okay?
- And let me say before you proceed,
I believe in this.
I'll just say that.
I believe in what you're about to do.
- Here's what I believe in.
- Okay.
Because we're all humans.
It's a public service.
Yes it's your trash can but
I'm not changing the dynamics
of your trash, you know I'm
not throwing a chair in there.
You know what I'm sayin'?
- Or a dead body.
- It's a bag of poop, it
doesn't change anything.
You should be okay with it.
When you're--
- Subject, okay,
I'm glad you're backing me up but subject
to some specific key points that I believe
and that I wanted to relay to Lily
'cause I needed her help.
I think the first thing is,
you gotta pick the right trash can.
There's a green one for--
- Oh of course.
- There's a blue one
for recycling, there's a black one.
And I'm like Lily, look up there.
I see some stragglers.
There's three trash cans.
What I want you to do and
this is my second point is--
- You're making your daughter do it?
- We gotta, the second point
is we gotta be clandestine.
You gotta be secret.
- You gotta be sneaky.
Even though I completely believe in it,
you still gotta be sneaky.
- 'Cause you never know
how a person's gonna feel
looking out their window
and seeing somebody open their trash can
and make a little deposit.
You don't know if they're gonna run out
with some sort of a firearm or at least--
- I doubt that would happen.
- Armed to the gills with insults.
- That could happen.
- In front of my daughter
and my beloved beast, Jade.
- 'Cause I will say that
if I saw it happen--
- You'd be mad.
You would feel anger instinctively.
- But I wouldn't say
anything 'cause I'd be like,
you know what, for all
the reasons I just said.
But I understand--
- But your heart rate would go up
and you'd have to do some breathing.
- The tendency to be protective
of your trash, I get it.
- It's your domain.
- It's not logical but I get it.
- So I'm like Lily,
we're gonna subtly scoot
over to the left side of the road.
As we're walking, we're
not gonna stop walking.
I want you to go up to the trash can,
I want you to gently lift
the lid like three inches.
All right, you don't have
to open it all the way.
I'm talking to her this way.
- This may be over instruction but okay.
- I'm like I just want you to just give me
a little poop bag gap and
then I'm gonna come in,
I'm gonna swoop in and I'm just gonna,
I'm gonna throw it in there--
- Hold on.
- And then you just gently let go.
- You made this a two person job?
- It has to be a two person job.
- If I was there I would have
been like this is a bad idea.
- Listen, you short-sighted amateur.
(Rhett chuckles)
I'm walking a dog with
a leash in one hand,
I got poop in a bag in the other hand
and I got a daughter with two free hands.
I gotta teach her the ways, man.
This is a teachable moment.
This is less about what I need
and more about what she needs.
- I would give her the poop
and let her do the whole shebang.
That's just what I would have done.
- Well that's because--
- Two hands.
- You're a cruel, unfeeling father.
- Lift with one, deposit with the other,
and she's also a young woman--
- I lead by example.
- Which I think gives her,
she's gonna get a little more leeway,
they're gonna be a little bit less likely
to come out cussing or with a firearm.
- Little less likely so
there's still a likelihood
that your daughter could be
blasted with poop bag insults.
And hey, if you're fine with that,
your daughter can be thrown to the wolves.
- Then she could be taught a lesson
and that would be the lesson.
How do you deal with that?
- So I'm like, I just need three inches.
And three seconds and I'll
take care of the rest.
And she's like, Dad, this isn't a heist.
- Yeah.
(Link chuckles)
I'm with her.
- I'm like sh, we're almost there.
Just don't, just do the plan.
(soft bass music)
And I'm talkin' like this now.
And--
- You probably look
suspicious, by the way.
- And then she grabs the green.
- The wrong one.
- No don't don't don't,
you gotta go with the black one.
You gotta go to the black,
and then she gives me
three inches on the black one
and I just make the deposit.
And then phew, we
immediately swing back over
to the other side of the
road and I'm like yes.
I think I literally out loud said yes.
- Yeah.
- And at that moment, I
looked up and I saw a car
with a person inside of
it and the door was open.
And I was like oh crap,
there's somebody there,
I think they saw us and I'm
like oh, nope, he didn't see us.
He was in his car detailing his dash.
- But he was the owner of the trash can.
- He was on the same
side of the trash can.
I would say most likely the man
in the car cleaning the dash
was the owner of the
three trash cans, yes.
- [Rhett] Mm-hmm.
- I panic for a moment.
- But as I stated before,
not really the owner.
They're on loan from the city.
- He's renting it.
- Yeah so we're all paying for it.
- Put yourself in his shoes, Rhett.
I was a bit afraid until I
realized and I told Lily,
"He didn't see it.
"He didn't see anything,
we have succeeded.
"We are amazing.
"You know what, I hope Jade craps again.
"Right now so we can just do it again."
It was exhilarating.
I was like on the edge.
The dude was like rubbin' his dash down
with some Armor All situation.
He was like me when I first
got my 1987 Nissan pickup
and I thought that I was gonna wax it
and it was already so
old that when I waxed it,
it basically just took
the paint off of it.
- You saw chrome underneath.
- Yeah.
It was like sheer metal.
The dude was going at
it, he never looked up.
I was like, oh, that's your fault, man.
You're too into your dash to
see who's making the stash
in your can.
- Okay, what happened though?
- Okay yeah I should
get on with this story.
So I walk by and we go
all the way to the end
of the road and then
we have to turn around
and we're walking back and I'm like,
oh, the guy's still
there and then I noticed
from this new vantage point
I can see the license plate
on the car and it says Dr. Noodle.
- Oh gosh.
- So then without saying anything to Lily,
as we're walking by,
again his door's open,
one foot's out and he's
still on that dash,
just grinding it.
He's just like--
- It's a dirty dash.
- (chuckles) It was a
shiny dash by this point.
We get up next to him
and I'm probably as far
from here to that wall
so like I don't know,
seven feet away.
And at that point, without
really planning out
what I'm gonna do, I just
went with the feeling.
- Surprise.
- I was feeling on top of the
world after what had happened
and I point at him.
And I say, "You must be Dr. Noodle."
And he looks up from his dash,
and the look on his
face went from surprise,
someone's speaking to me,
to jaw-dropping amazement
and he says, "You know me?"
(Rhett laughs)
And then, before I could
say anything in response,
he said, "I know you too."
(Rhett laughs)
And I never stopped walking.
- What?
- I never stopped walking
and I said, "Cool, man.
"You have a good day."
- Oh gosh, man, you're
such a moron. (laughs)
- And then Lily leans over--
- Oh gosh.
- As we're still walking, she leans over--
- You were afraid of him
because of what you had done.
That's why you didn't stop.
- Lily leaned over and she
said, "What's happening?"
(chuckles)
I was like, we just met Dr. Noodle.
That's what's happening, then
we walked around the corner.
- Well who the hell is Dr. Noodle?
- Well, I don't know, he's that guy.
But here's the thing,
he had this amazing look
on his face and it was as if
I had gone up to Clark Kent
on the streets of Metropolis
with his glasses on
and I said, "You must be Superman."
It was one of those, oh.
You know me?
It was like, what?
It's like when someone has a
name tag on and they forget
and you think you're
cute because you're like,
Steve, what's up, and
they're like (gasps),
you know me?
- Right.
- But people don't typically
say, "You know me?"
But then he also--
- But you know--
- He also knew me.
- Since then.
- I guess from the internet.
- Since then, he has
realized why you said that.
- I walked around, what do you mean?
Because of his license plate.
- He saw the license plate.
He realizes--
- But he did know me I guess from--
- Why did you, you didn't
stop subconsciously because--
- I was walking a dog,
I wasn't standing a dog.
- You may not even realize
why you didn't stop.
You didn't stop because you
felt guilt over the poop.
- Walked around the corner
and guess what we saw?
We saw the other car
from that vantage point,
it said Mr. Noodle, we
were like, look, Lily.
One down, one to go.
One day we might just
get to meet Mr. Noodle.
- Hold on it's the same house, right?
- Yeah but I'd like to think there's a Dr.
and a Mr. Noodle living there.
There's two cars.
- But you met the doctor.
- I met the doctor.
- I'm just really interested in,
he obviously does something.
- I think he's a dash doctor.
He's a car doctor.
Update to the story just to provide
a little color commentary--
- What I'm saying is
you could have found out by just stopping.
- I didn't wanna have
a conversation, Rhett.
I was just being nice.
I think I made his day.
- Okay.
- Maybe he made yours through that story.
I was walking Jade yesterday
and I walked past Dr. Noodle
and daggum if he wasn't out
there again, second time,
and guess what he was doing.
He had the hood open of the same car.
- He was cleaning the engine?
- He was cleaning the engine.
- Yeah he's getting
ready to sell that car.
'Cause cleaning the
engine doesn't do anything
except make people think
that your car is cool.
(Link chuckles)
You know what I'm saying?
Look how clean this engine is.
- I think he just had--
- It's gonna go another
10,000 miles.
- He's a shine doctor.
He's the doctor of car shine.
You know me?
- What kinda car is it?
- I know you too.
- Is it like a car that he
would take to a car show?
- It was like an Accord.
- Yeah, he's going to the Accord car show.
- So anyway, he recognized
me and I will say
that's probably the most
enjoyment I've ever had
over being recognized, spoiler alert.
- Oh it's all downhill from there.
In the negative sense.
- Maybe not 'cause I
don't wanna be negative
about being recognized so
let's wrestle with that.
- You know what, we're gonna be honest
about being recognized.
But first we're gonna let
you know that you can get
a snotebook or two.
- Dramatic leaning inwards.
Here you got the Good Mythical Snotebook,
it's a notebook and a sketchbook in one.
- And this is just the Mythical Snotebook.
- Blank pages, tabula rosa.
Just like my brain.
- Now this one I was
told not to open it up
because it'd show you
because it's from Zack
but I'm just gonna read a
little bit of Zack's diary.
There's nothing in here.
- So there's nothing in
there, it was just a test.
- People actually, no, there's
something at the beginning
but I'm not gonna look at it or read it.
It was just a bit.
Wasn't this designed by
our very own Kaitlyn?
Yeah, she draws this on every single one.
Every single one is hand-drawn.
It's quite a deal, no,
she hand drew it once
and then we printed it
on all the rest of 'em.
So record your thoughts,
your feelings and your life
with a snotebook at Mythical.snore, snore.
(both laugh)
- Oh we got a sleep study going.
Sign up for the Mythical sleep study.
Mythical.snore.
- Hopefully this podcast
is not a sleep study.
- Do I have Kleenex or snot on my face?
- Yeah you got some, kinda yeah.
But don't dash it.
Don't do it like Dr. Noodle rubs his dash
'cause eventually it'll turn red.
You don't wanna overdo it.
Just put some Armor All on
there, protect yourself.
- Is it gone?
- Yeah.
Okay so...
We're gonna explore the dynamic.
We've talked about this from time to time.
If you've listened to the show for awhile,
you know that we tell the story or two
about being recognized in certain places
and what we said and what the person said.
We might retread a few of
those but we're doing it
in the context of answering
this question of like,
what does it do for us?
Mentally, emotionally, what is it like
to be recognized in public
and how do we deal with it,
what do we think about it?
And this could come across as a little bit
like self-aggrandizing I think is the word
that you used when we were
thinking about doing this--
- Yeah when I pitched
the topic, I was like,
let's do something self-aggrandizing.
- Yeah.
- You know like talk about
how often we're recognized.
- Yeah but we're doing it
because we have this conversation
and I think that because
you listener are perhaps
the kind of person that
if you saw us in public,
you might feel like you
had to Dr. Noodle us.
And (chuckles) if you do,
then this might give a little perspective.
And I don't know where it's gonna go.
There's no agenda.
We're not trying to land at some sort
of public recognition ethic or anything.
Maybe we will by the end of this.
I have a little story
that I can start with
that happened recently
and I think it kinda feeds into a part
of my perspective on this and that is,
I think part of the positive for me
and this is just a
totally selfish positive
is that there are times
that I am with someone.
Might be my family, it might be friends,
and getting recognized
when I'm with someone,
it gives you just a
little, I got recognized.
You know what I'm saying?
- Yeah.
- It's sort of the self-centered
egotistical part of me
responds to the fact that hey,
I was in a group of people
and I got recognized.
And then when you're with your family--
- Someone that you care
about their opinion of you.
- Right and then if I'm
with my mom gets such a kick
out of it.
- Right.
- My mom will introduce herself.
My mom will be in a conversation
with somebody in public
and then just in the
middle of the conversation,
just throw out, "Do you
know Rhett and Link?"
Just so that she can be
like, "Well Rhett's my son."
(laughs)
- Right.
- So if I'm out in public
and then we get recognized,
she gets a kick out of that so
I kinda get a kick out of it.
Well, my brother and his
boys recently came out
to spend some time with
us and we took 'em down
to the west side, the only
time you go to the west side
if you live on the east side is when
you've got family in town.
You don't ever go over
there on your own volition.
It's just like oh we got people in town,
let's show 'em Los
Angeles that we never see.
So we went to--
- You talkin' Santa Monica?
- We went to Santa Monica.
- You talkin' Venice Beach?
- We didn't do Venice Beach.
We have done Venice Beach
with them, but you know,
you need that like once every five years.
So we were at Third Street Promenade,
you know the outdoor mall
situation down there.
We go into the Urban
Outfitters because you know,
it's different over there. (chuckles)
- I guess.
- I mean it just feels
different, it's the west side.
No so we're going through
and then all of a sudden
I realize that there is
a dog just, a bulldog,
an American bulldog.
- Are you about to tell
me you got recognized
by a bulldog?
- (chuckles) Well.
- 'Cause that is a first, man.
- There's an American bulldog--
- There are cats that watch
Good Mythical Morning.
I hate to tell you that but
we get lots of screenshots
of cats watching out show.
- You think you get lots
of screenshots, yeah, people
send 'em to me all the time.
- But not as much dogs.
- I appreciate the views,
I mean, it still adds to the ad revenue
even if it is a cat,
but this American bulldog is
walking around without a leash
in Urban Outfitters and I was like,
is this what they do on the west side?
They have mascots that roam the stores?
- Please tell me that he spoke English.
Please.
- And then I hear someone
say the dog's name
which I don't remember,
let's just say Spot,
which it wasn't.
Spot!
Get over here!
And I look up and the source of the voice
and ostensibly, the owner
of the dog, Dennis Quaid.
- Dennis Quaid?
- Dennis Quaid.
- Now for those of you
who don't fully know
who Dennis Quaid is--
- Okay that's what my story's about.
- Okay 'cause okay.
- Okay so right.
Dennis Quaid is--
- 'Cause all I was about
to say was I can't answer that exactly.
- Dennis Quaid was a very,
very, very famous movie star,
right, like back in the
time of movie stars,
like back when if you were
in movies in the '80s,
so big frickin' deal right,
celebrity culture was way,
way smaller so he kinda comes
from that old guard.
- What's his biggest movie?
- Oh gosh.
- Can you look that up, but keep going.
- He's been in a bunch of stuff.
He continues to act,
he's in a new insurance
campaign or whatever but--
- Oh.
- He had on snakeskin boots first of all
which was impressive.
So my brother obviously
gets a huge kick out of this
because he's a 40 something year old man
and so obviously he
knows who Dennis Quaid is
and we got a kick out of
the fact that Dennis Quaid
has a dog off-leash in Santa Monica.
- In an Urban Outfitters.
- Which seems like the kinda
thing that you would feel
like you had the right to
do if you were Dennis Quaid,
you know what I'm saying,
it's like, I can do anything,
I was a movie star in the
'80s, I can walk around
with my dog off its leash.
I do have to tell it to come
to me over and over again
but a leash would help with that.
But Cole got a big kick out of it
and then he's literally saying kinda what
you were getting at.
Cole's like, kinda crazy, comin' in here,
you see Dennis Quaid
but these kids in here,
they probably more readily
recognize you than Dennis Quaid.
They probably don't even
know who Dennis Quaid is.
Literally five seconds later
a group of four teenage girls
walked by us and they were
saying, "That was Dennis Quaid."
(both laughing)
- Are you serious?
(sighs happily)
Really?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Really?
- That was Dennis Quaid.
- You know why, 'cause he was in the movie
about the dolphin girl.
- Parent Trap.
- He was in Parent Trap.
That was a remake of Parent Trap.
- Dolphin girl's not Parent Trap,
I just saw Jacob held up Parent Trap.
- What's the dolphin girl?
- Free Willy?
(Link sputters)
- Not unless her leg was Willy.
She got a leg bitten off.
- By a dolphin?
- No by a shark.
- That's a, dolphin.
(Link laughing)
You mean the girl that lost an arm?
- She lost her arm to a shark.
- Soul Surfer or something like that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, he
was the dad in that.
- Yeah.
- That's how they know him.
No dolphins involved.
- But they know his name,
you know what I'm saying?
People watch--
- And then,
what about you though?
- Well I will say that
then they did see me
and they did, it's not as good of a story
when they recognized me but
they did also recognize me.
- Was that after you asked
'em if they knew who you were?
- I did not approach them.
They saw me and then one
of the girls was like,
it's crazy, we're seeing
everybody in here,
or something like that.
So anyway, that Dennis Quaid, man.
Shout-out to Dennis.
If you wanna hang out at the dog park
where you don't need a leash,
the only appropriate place
where the dogs don't need
to be on a leash, hit us up.
- A lot of people, like I said at the top,
when they recognize me, like
last night we were walking
to meet friends including
you and Jessie at,
where were we, Highland Park.
- Yeah.
- Somebody comes around
the corner like, hey man, let me,
I know you, can I take
a little video with you?
And I'm like, oh, video.
Ooh, I'm always like we
can just grab a selfie,
but I didn't say that.
- That's interesting 'cause I
got a video request as well.
- He said video and usually they'll ask,
can you say so and so to this person?
But instead he just
held it up like a selfie
as if it was a photo but he
was doing video and I waved.
I was like uh, that's actually
never happened before.
And then he said, "Does
this happen a lot?"
So whenever I'm recognized,
I do get that follow-up.
I do think that like you
said, people wanna know
if they're the only one that does this
or if they're maybe I guess,
am I being annoying because
this has happened five times
as you rounded the block.
So I guess I'll answer
that question a little bit
in the middle.
I think it does happen a lot,
and basically, every
single time I go out now,
it's multiple times.
I had to run errands
with the kids and I went
to the grocery store and
then the drug store next door
and then we got in the
car and drove a block away
and went to this poke bowl place.
I walked in the grocery
store and I got recognized.
And then I was checking
out at the drug store
and I got recognized.
And then we went to the poke bowl place
and the guy working
there said something else
that I've started to get more frequently
and that is the question,
"Has anyone ever told you
"that you look a lot like
a guy from the internet?"
- That happens quite a bit.
- And so what I say to
that is, "I do get that.
"A lot actually."
And the reason why I
say that is 'cause like,
one of my kids is usually with
me and I like messin' around
with people and making them feel like,
and Lily was like, Dad. (sighs)
This is not a heist, no she
said that for the other one.
For this thing she said, "It is him.
"He likes to mess with people."
Because when we were, I
think I told this story,
when we were in London at
the Harry Potter thing,
these kids were like, excuse me, sir.
Have you ever--
- Tiny Tim.
- Have you ever been told
that you look like--
- They all sound like Tiny Tim.
- You look like someone from the internet.
I'm like yes, exactly.
I get it a lot that I
look exactly like someone
from the internet, exactly,
and I kept saying that
and they nodded their
heads and walked off.
Then they came back later and got pictures
because I was in a confined
environment where we were all
going through a tour together.
(sighs) I mean, after,
I should just say that
it's frickin' surreal to
find yourself walking around
and just, it's happening,
I don't know if we're the
most popular we ever been
but it's happening more now than ever.
Like it continues to happen more and more.
- Right.
- I think it's the nature
of just the popularity of the medium.
Like more and more people are watching,
even if you don't watch our videos,
you can't escape our thumbnails.
So I think, and that brings me to a theory
about something else which
I'm sure we'll get into
about what you hear people saying a lot,
but I don't know if we're the
most popular we've ever been
but we're the most visible.
And I guess maybe they're the same thing.
So it's happening a lot
and I just wanna say
I'm extremely grateful
because it's an indicator--
- Right.
- Of things working,
like oh, we create our stuff to be seen
and so when people see it
and we get recognized more,
that's like that's a good
sign, oh this is working.
It's also freakin' surreal
because in my innermost being,
I have a hard time
actually thinking of myself
as a famous person.
It's like I don't think of
myself as an adult either
a lot of times, I mean, I
know how my brain works.
I know the thoughts and feelings
and processes I go through
and I feel like I might as well be
in fourth grade a lot of times, you know?
- I can attest to that.
- And in a similar way,
I feel like I know who famous people are.
I mean, I've seen Parent Trap,
the remake with Dennis Quaid.
But I just don't feel like
I'm one of those people
but you know what, I guess I am
because I get recognized everywhere I go.
- And I think there's a few dynamics.
One is, like you said, it's an indicator,
so be grateful.
It can be a little bit
of a nuisance, at times.
Now in the moment I never,
I wanna make this clear,
in the moment, unless somebody
says or does something
that is particularly annoying
which we'll get into,
I appreciate it and there's
nothing against an individual
who comes up and recognizes me.
But it's sometimes going
into the situation,
knowing that it could happen,
that's what's annoying,
not the person who did
it but just the dynamic
of the fact that it could happen.
For instance,
we were coming back from someplace
and I was like I'd like to make some,
I can't remember what it was,
I think I wanted to make some burgers
and I'd watch the YouTube video
about the perfect skillet
burger or whatever
and I was like I'm
gonna make these burgers
with this really nice beef or whatever
and Jessie's like okay
well I don't have any
of that stuff so let's just
go by the grocery store.
And we pull up to the
grocery store and I'm like,
can you go?
She was super tired, she was
like, I don't wanna go in.
If you wanna cook this stuff, you go in.
I was like, I don't wanna
go in because I just,
I really don't wanna be
recognized right now.
It wasn't like I was having
a bad hair day or something.
Sometimes I get into
the grocery store and--
- Well you have to be--
- I have to have
multiple interactions.
- Yeah and they have
to be for that person.
Every interaction you
have is for that person,
it's not for you.
I don't go into the grocery store unless
I'm taking someone I
wanna impress I guess.
I don't go into these
places saying I wanna stop
and have interactions.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- That are for that person
to make them feel special.
- Sometimes you might be in that mood
which I wanna talk about
that, but sometimes you're
in the I don't wanna get recognized mood
because I just wanna get in and get out--
- No one would win.
- Because I want the
interaction to be something
that is positive and
memorable to this person
'cause I do care about
anyone who watches what we do
enough to know who we are,
I care about that person.
So I don't wanna be an, to
this person even if I'm feeling
particularly like an, at the time.
So Jessie was like you're
not gonna get recognized
at the grocery store.
She was basically trying to manipulate me
so I would be the one to go in.
'Cause she had her feet up on the dash.
- Oh she did.
- Speaking of dirty dashes.
(Rhett laughs)
- I know a guy--
- I need to call Dr. Noodle to buff out
those Doc Marten stains. (chuckles)
But so, not a sponsor.
I don't know why I felt
the need to say what brand
of shoes my wife had on at the time.
- I thought you were saying
Dr. Noodle's not a sponsor.
But he will be.
- So Locke and I go in together.
Literally I walk in
to the grocery store
and I'm like where are the,
what do you call the things?
Carrying things.
- [Both] Baskets.
- I was like where are the baskets at,
and a guy was like oh, right over here.
You from Good Mythical Morning? (chuckles)
It was literally the
first guy we talked to
and Locke just got a kick
out of it 'cause he was like
Mom said you wouldn't get recognized
and then it happened two more
times in the seven minutes
that I was getting the three
ingredients that I needed.
And again it's not like it
was some big inconvenience
but it was just like,
again, you feel like,
if this person has a question,
I wanna give them the time that,
this is a one chance
and they wanna have an
interaction that's special
or whatever and so but I just
wanna get burgers and go.
But then there's the
opposite end of the spectrum
which is I remember
one time our friend Gar
who we met Tony Hale through
and obviously Tony at this
point is like a huge star
and would be recognized
basically anywhere that he went,
at the time he was pretty much known
for Arrested Development.
- Yeah.
Veep had not started.
- Veep had not started,
yeah and he wasn't gonna be
the frickin' main character
in the upcoming Toy Story.
- Were you up for that role or something?
Why'd you get angry?
(Rhett laughs)
My friend got more famous, gah!
- I'm not angry, no.
But in fact, if anybody should get
what he's gotten, it's him.
- Absolutely, yeah.
- But Gar said, you know,
he was joking 'cause Gar
has this way of finding
this thing out about you or
assuming something about you
in a way that it's just funny, right.
- Yeah yeah.
- So he was like,
you know, whenever Tony needs
a self-confidence boost,
he just goes to the Apple Store. (laughs)
- 'Cause they're Arrested Development.
- Right because the
people who work at Apple
and/or shop at Apple at the time,
Gar's joke was that there
was a lot of crossover,
those people were the
Arrested Development crowd
and they would recognize him.
Now he didn't actually go to the,
he went to the Apple
Store to get a product,
but that was Gar's little
joke is he was like
anytime he's been with
him in an Apple Store,
he's gotten recognized so he must do this
for self-confidence boosts.
- Whenever we wanna get
a self-confidence boost,
we go to the meat section in a Ralphs.
- (chuckles) That's right.
That's where the Mythical Beasts hang out.
- No I was making a
statement more about us
and our proclivity to
eat butchered refuse.
- But I will say--
- So the back of the butcher counter.
The stuff they don't put out front.
- Those are the two dynamics, right.
There's the I'm in a situation right now
where I'm at the airport
and I'm trying to move
to a location or I'm at an amusement park
and I don't want to suddenly
have to get a picture
with somebody 'cause that
might lead to this other person
wanting a picture and this
other person wanting a picture.
There are situations like that where
it seems like an inconvenience
and then there are times
where it's just like, you know what,
and this is never something that you think
but it's just like oh I'm
with these people right now,
or I'm in this place right now.
I'm in this place that
I think the people here
are particularly cool or something.
I have some reason to think
that these people have
a particular taste in comedy,
boy it'd be cool to get recognized here.
Again, this isn't an actual
conscious thought process
but this is sort of the
emotional undercurrent
that is happening from time to time.
'Cause you remember when we were--
- There are times when
we wanna be recognized
like I'm in this, I'm
in Melbourne, Australia,
and I think this is one
of the coolest places
I've ever been and then if I feel like I'm
in one of the coolest
places I've ever been,
if somebody with a cool
backpack meets me on the bridge
going over the river and I get recognized,
even if they don't know that
we have a show that night,
I can get over that because I'm like,
oh that was a cool backpack.
I really, I like that
person's taste in backpacks.
And they like my show so hmm,
there's a correlation there.
- I'm cool. (laughs)
Right.
- Therefore, I am cool.
- Right.
- Well you remember,
so we were in New York and
we were lower east side
or something, we're walking along
and there are six to eight
guys sitting on this stoop
and basically like it feels
like a television show,
it's like this is a scene from a movie,
this isn't normal, this isn't--
- It was nighttime and it
was a bit seedier than,
this wasn't network TV, this was like,
this could be a scene
in an HBO seedy movie.
- Like The Wire.
- Yeah.
- But it wasn't Baltimore,
it was New York.
And so you got these guys
kinda sitting on this stoop--
- Not seedy but gritty.
Let's say gritty.
- And some guys who were sort
of embodying the grittiness
of the area, shall we say.
- Right.
We were fish out of water walking by.
- We walk by, we actually get past them,
and all of a sudden, a guy's like hold up!
- We might have even sped up, honestly.
- Rhett and Link?
And I'm like what?
And then a guy who I'm just describing him
because he's actually known
on the internet for this.
He calls himself T-Rex, I
think he's got an Instagram.
But he does not have arms, he has hands.
He just has hands and no arms.
And he wears this as a badge of honor.
He didn't have a shirt on.
It's his thing, he has fully embraced it.
- Yeah.
- And so he comes up to us and he's like,
I'm a big fan.
And he's tellin' the other
guys and another guy's like,
yeah I know who they are or whatever.
And then I was blown away,
I was like this interesting
combination of the coolest guys
who've ever recognized us
are saying that they're fans
and then he explained
who he was and he puts
on a T-Rex head and goes
around and does T-Rex motions.
(Link chuckles)
- Yeah it was wild, it was wild.
- But that was this thing that
we talk about that all the time
because it was just like those guys watch.
- Yeah we're in each
other's orbits, it's weird.
- And 'cause--
- In a cool way.
- Again, I feel like I
wanna constantly apologize
for, we're just trying to
be honest about the way
our thoughts work, it's like
I'm not trying to be like
oh look we get recognized by cool people.
I'm trying to explain the
psyche of what it does to you
and what it could do to us.
I could easily see how
this could become something
that you sort of rely on like
an injection into your arm.
You know what I'm saying?
- So I think a healthier response is to,
if I'm gonna err on the side of something,
it's being over it versus desiring it,
so I guess it's a good
sign that the struggle
that we have is being gracious
and continuing to be grateful.
So being gracious to the
person no matter what they say,
if it's awkward or if it's
unintentionally insulting.
- Well yeah.
- Which happens a lot.
- That's a whole category we can get into.
- That's a whole category,
but then switching to
being gracious, like
you said, and grateful.
So how we feel about it.
And so we can land there
in a few minutes I think
and also talk about
boundaries 'cause I'm starting
to think about that and I have one story
but before we do, I do think that
there are unintentionally
insulting things,
I think we've talked about these
before and it's just funny.
It's not that we're
actually, well I don't know.
Maybe go through and then we'll see if--
- There's one situation where--
- If it actually hurts or
if it's just kinda funny
and that's why we're talking about it.
- I told the story before
about the one time I was
at the airport and we were panicking,
we had missed a flight
and somebody came up
and I think I was probably
as short as I have ever been
with somebody but...
I don't think I'm
exaggerating, 70% of the time,
people say one of two things.
One is I used to watch you all the time.
- Right.
- And the second thing is
my fill in the blank, cousin, sister, kid,
mom, brother, is the biggest fan.
- Somebody besides me.
- Somebody besides the person
who's coming up to you.
So 70, and this is just
anecdotal but 70% of the time,
somebody says something
that basically says that,
me currently, the one coming up to you,
I'm not a fan, I don't care. (chuckles)
I used to care or somebody else cares.
- Right.
- And so that's--
- So I'm bothering you to tell you
that I'm not really into you
is the worst interpretation.
- And basically what I say every time is,
if somebody says my so
and so is a big fan,
I'm like, you're not?
That's what I say.
And then if somebody says I used to watch,
I'm like why'd you stop?
Because I mean, I'm not being a jerk,
I'm just legitimately like okay.
- Well it's a little jerkish.
They say I used to watch, I'll say,
like the guy in the poke
bowl place who I had to wait
for the order so we
ended up talking to him
for like eight minutes.
But the kick-off was I used to watch you.
After he said, "Has anyone
told you you look like
"the guy from the internet
that I used to watch,"
I guess, you put it all together.
And I'm like well we're
still doing it man.
And that's when it starts to feel like
we're getting recognized more
but we got all these people
who are recognizing us
for not watching anymore.
What does that mean, we're falling off
and it plays into my
insecurities, I'm like ugh.
So that's not healthy.
- Well, first of all, I think
if you're talking about
our emotional state,
this is good right?
This is good.
I don't want to be somebody
who is constantly like--
- Adulated.
- Adulated and built up
by other people 'cause A,
it makes me feel a little uncomfortable,
but also it turns you into a jerk.
It's very difficult if you
are just a normal person.
Even if you're a normal,
well-adjusted person who,
this all happened to us
after we were fully adults
with kids, married, we got
lots of things in our lives
that ground us, but even
with all those things
in place, if suddenly
everyone cares about you
because of something you did
and they wanna be around you
or they, that can create problems.
You can become a person that
no one wants to be around
so we are constantly
guarding against that,
but it helps when 70% of the
time people recognize you,
they're kind of insulting you.
- Well--
- It kinda balances things out.
- Obviously they're not
intentionally insulting us
and I think it's an insecurity that leads
to it being interpreted as an insult
but it's also a good thing,
it's also a position indicator
that our work is getting out there
and again, I wanna talk about our work
and not talk about us because
that's what I want this
to be about, it's the stuff that we create
even if we're the center
of the show or whatever.
It's a sign that it's getting
out there to the point
where even if you don't
watch it, you know about it.
People say millions in marketing
for just that to happen.
Awareness, not even enjoyment.
- Yeah.
- Awareness is arguably
just as powerful, it's
like I've got an opinion
about something that I
don't even actively watch.
- I think that's evidenced
by, so you're kinda talking
about people who--
- That's a good sign.
- Aren't familiar and this is something
that has happened
repeatedly that demonstrates
what you're talking about
is definitely the case
that people just kind of know.
A, they don't know the name of the show.
B, they don't know our names.
But the most interesting and
funniest thing that's happened
is I'll be with someone who is not you.
(Link chuckles)
Okay.
This most recently
happened with my brother,
same trip when he was in town.
And somebody came up and
they were like, ah, oh, uh,
you're that guy.
You're that guy from the internet.
And I helped him, I was like
yeah Good Mythical Morning.
They're like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah.
And then my brother's
with me and they're like,
and you're the other guy.
And my brother was like yeah!
(both chuckle)
- 'Cause he's your brother
and that's a thing that--
- So we got a picture--
- Right with what?
- The two of us got a
picture with this woman.
That's happened like five times.
- Ironically was I not like
a block and a half away
and we had just split up
to go in different stores
at that moment.
- No that wasn't that day,
that was a different day.
- 'Cause that happened then too.
No someone got a picture with
you and you didn't tell 'em
that I was across the
street, you spared me.
- Yeah yeah, a lot of times
people are like where's Link?
And 99% of the time I'm
like, well, I don't know.
I don't have a geotag on him or whatever.
- Right I have one on you
so I tell them exactly
where you are, that's why
you get recognized so much.
People are going after you.
- In that moment,
you were literally on the
opposite street corner.
- I was watching it happen.
- Where's Link, I don't know.
I currently see him over
your shoulder. (laughs)
But I'm not gonna sick 'em on you.
- Sometimes I like to, if
people are takin' a picture
with you, I like to sneak
up at the last second
and get in the photo, kinda
like how really famous people do
when they're like in the Marvel universe
and then they show up
and sneak in the photos.
- Well and that, 'cause you
know what you were talking
about with, I don't feel, again,
I watched that documentary
about Bill Murray
which by the way, I don't
know if I could recommend it
because I was kind of
annoyed by the filmmaker
and I just didn't like
the way the film was made
but I really like Bill Murray
and I really like these
stories about people.
- He shows up at places.
- He shows up
and he does these things and he's Bill.
We're not Bill Murray but I
also have this abiding sense
that I could never do
that because I'm this guy
from the internet.
There may be some circles
that if I showed up,
me and you showed up, it would
be a big deal for people,
but for the majority of people,
there's one person in the
group who knows who we are
and then everyone else starts asking,
who are those guys?
And then people start asking us.
- Oh that's the worst.
- That happened in a
coffee shop the other day.
We were down in Seal Beach
where Locke had some basketball games
and he had a game in the
afternoon and a game at night
so we had all this time to
kill, we're walking around,
go into this coffee shop.
- All these seals to
kill, what did you say?
- Time to kill.
- Okay good.
- At Seal Beach.
- Okay, better.
- Did not kill any seals.
Didn't even see any.
- Did you have a club?
- It's a misnomer.
- They show up when you have a club.
- I go into the coffee shop
and the girl working the
register is like oh hey.
A big fan of your show.
And we had a pleasant interaction.
- That's perfect.
- And then an older woman
who was in line behind me,
she was like, well what do you do?
- Oh gosh.
- This happens quite a bit.
- I hate having to explain
what I do to people
who don't actually care.
- Well ever since...
A few dozen times, I
was like, I got a show
on the internet that, you know.
Well what do you do on the show?
That conversation, that annoys me, okay.
And all the things that happen
with getting recognized,
that is the thing that
annoys me the most is
you're making me tell
you why someone that,
so what I do now, whether
it's a child who recognizes me
and the parents are like
why do they, I say--
- I feel like it's even
worse with the parents
because they have a
relationship with the person
who knows us so that could be an easy way
to have a conversation.
- It was worse when I lean
over, I turn to the girl
who was waiting on me at the cash register
and I said, "She'll tell
you all about it." (laughs)
- Oh.
- So that's what I do now,
it's like what do you?
I say, "Well, ask her."
I mean, I know that
I'm putting that person
in a situation and I know
that I'm kinda seeming like
a complete jerk now, I've told
you that the way I respond
to these things but it happens,
I just had these sort of back
pocket responses for people.
I used to watch, why'd you stop?
- May I make a suggestion?
I think if you tweak your
language a little bit,
it could be a little
more self-deprecating.
Like instead of saying, "Ask her."
Even with the up at the end.
- I say it nicely.
- Well I know
you say it nicely.
But you could go a step further
and you could say something like,
"I think it would be better
hearing it from her."
And then it's like, what?
- I think the tone--
- He's embarrassed
to talk about what he does,
he must be a porn star.
- I think the tone of,
I say, you know what--
- Then you got her.
- I say--
- Then she's afraid to ask.
- I say it in a joking way.
In all those responses.
- I know, I know.
- So I say, "She'll tell ya all about it."
And then it usually just results in
no one saying anything else
and I just get my coffee
and start drinking it.
- Yeah that's, I don't like that either.
When the parent
asking multiple questions to figure out
why the kid likes us.
I mean it's like you know--
- Well it'd be one thing if
it was like I'm an actor.
It's like--
- Right, right,
it's hard to explain.
- If I tell you I'm a YouTuber,
you'll have a question about that,
and then if I tell you
what I do on YouTube,
you'll have a question about that.
- Right.
- And then you'll just
be like why's my child a fan of this?
- It's the same principle
as if you do get a selfie
with somebody at an amusement
park or crowded area,
like a mall or something,
then there is a chance
that a little line will form.
Which brings me to, I think
the biggest sensitivity
to this whole thing is
being out with our families.
Because it really puts a wrench,
we don't make public plans in
the family that involve adding
10% margin to accommodate
for us being stopped,
me being stopped.
And then having to separate from me
so that they won't be
in the photo, you know.
And then so I think it's...
it really tests their patience
and I fully understand that.
Or do I?
I was at, we went to the
Shazam movie premiere
and it was thrilling.
We did Instagram stories
like I had Shando with me
and you in the Ferris wheel,
with my wife by the way, right?
- No.
I was with my--
- Were you?
- Your wife and your daughter--
- Were in the Ferris wheel.
- Different cart.
- Okay and she's afraid
of heights so I wanted
to watch her be in a Ferris wheel
but I'm glad you weren't there.
In such a tender moment.
- Did she have a difficult time?
- I think she did great,
she overcame some sort
of Ferris wheel fear.
They frickin' shut down
the Hollywood Boulevard
and set up a whole carnival.
And then it was just
invite only, you know,
fortunately we got in on that.
And we're walking around,
getting free fair food
and all this stuff and
then Christy turns to Lily
when I'm standing there, she's like,
look it's Sterling K. Brown.
One of the stars of This Is Us,
the show that even
mentioning it makes you cry.
(Rhett sniffles)
They both love the show
and they bonded over it
and I know who the guy is,
I haven't watched the show
and of course we had the
other guy from This Is Us
on Good Mythical Morning.
- Chris.
- Chris Sullivan, absolutely.
Anyway, Sterling has not been on our show.
We had never met him but
when my wife and my daughter
are talking about how much of a connection
they make with the show and
they're like geeking out
and I actually think that Christy,
I'm gonna pull her under
the bus with me here,
I do think she said, "Maybe
we can get a picture."
He's sittin' right there.
He and his son who was like grade school,
were enjoying some fair food on a bench.
We were standing there
whispering about him.
I just was like I'll ask him for a photo.
And they're like oh oh, okay.
And I go up there and I'm
like, Sterling, how you doing?
And I shook his hand,
I was like, I'm Link.
I just wanna let you know,
boy, as I'm telling this,
there's a lot of faux pas
here that we've discussed.
The first thing I said was--
- I used to be a fan.
- My wife and daughter
are huge fans.
Would you mind if I snapped a photo?
So again, I was like--
- I feel like, go on, but I
feel like that's different.
Because they were there.
- Yeah it is different.
- And I'm not annoyed
by it, I'm just saying,
it's just the case that
most people say that.
- And Sterling K. Brown said--
- No.
- His face changed to
this apologetic, yet kind,
I can make you cry at
will on television face.
He said, "This is really
family time for me and my son,
"so I'm gonna need to pass."
I don't know if he said
I'm gonna need to pass
but he said something
the most gracious way.
I was like hmm, I'm gonna write that down.
And then I walked away, totally,
I felt like a total jack
for asking him for the photo.
And then I turn around
and I yelled at Christy
and Lily in front of everybody,
"Look what you made me do!"
No I didn't, I was like,
he's having family time.
And I was like, and then
it clicked for them too
and they're like, all three
of us, it clicked in our minds
I think at that moment, it's like wait,
I bet we could have that too.
You know, it was like the tables--
- We could have family time.
- The tables turned where
it was like what if,
learning from my mentor,
Sterling K. Brown,
I adopted a similar
mantra when it came to,
I'm out in public but
I'm having special time
with my wife or my kids.
- This is a difficult one.
- I respected him totally and I felt--
- I have no judgment of him, by the way.
- I felt bad for asking him.
I felt like--
- Did you talk to him
the other night at that thing?
He did not recognize, we went
to a party and he was there
and we might tell more of the
details of that party later
so I wanna save it.
- Okay.
- Except for the fact
that I shook his hand
and I looked in his eyes
and I was like, is he gonna
recognize me as that guy?
- No, I'm sure he wouldn't.
- He didn't.
Even though it was me and Christy there.
- This is interesting because
okay, at that same thing--
- 'Cause I wanna talk
about these boundaries,
that's what I'm getting at.
- 'Cause at the same premiere,
a number of people, 10,
I don't know, came up--
- And asked to get pictures with us.
- And got pictures with
us and some people,
like one of 'em was, it
was a mom, she came up
and she was like, my son is a huge fan.
And he was there and turns out,
he was in the freakin' movie.
He was one of the kids
in the family in Shazam.
And we, and that, I think
two things are going on.
Number one, we don't see
ourselves on the level
of Sterling K. Brown, right,
I know there are some people
who are like that's ridiculous.
There's no difference
between what you do and,
well I'm just telling you, I
see him as a real celebrity
and I see myself as a
YouTuber and I know that's,
I'm selling the whole
platform short by saying that
but just mentally, because
anybody can make a YouTube video.
Not anybody can just go and say,
I'm on an episode of This Is Us.
You can make your own show on YouTube
just as easily as we can.
So it just feels like it's--
- Or can you?
- It feels like there's a
different thing going on.
Maybe he has experienced, well, if I come,
I'm bringing my kid to this thing
and if I get a picture with one person,
it would lead to a picture
with, and all of a sudden,
this is about me and not about my son.
So I completely understand that.
But for me when we were
at the Shazam premiere,
I always feel like we shouldn't
be there, imposter syndrome.
I'm like how did we, we're just
two guys from North Carolina
who just kinda got lucky and nobody knows
that we're just a couple of
dumb rednecks that just know
how to put hair product in.
- And maybe if Sterling K. Brown sees us
get a picture with somebody,
then something will,
maybe we can be friends with him.
- Exactly, and so when
you're in this mode,
yeah, I got to admit, it's like oh,
the other real celebrities here.
If somebody wants a picture with me,
there's that dynamic and so,
but Sterling K. Brown is not
thinking about it like that.
He isn't trying to impress anybody.
- Right.
- And so,
I guess when you get to this centered,
balanced place, you can say things like
I'm having family time right
now so I'm gonna have to pass.
And you say that without apology.
So are you now saying that
that is what you're gonna say
when you're with your family?
- I think I'm going to,
when I go into certain situations.
If it's a special event
that I'm bringing one of
my kids to because they
are particularly excited
about that and it is
about, hey I'm bringing you
to this thing, we're talking about it,
and there's a buildup to
it and then we get there
and I'm spending 10% of my
time taking photos with people,
I think that that sends,
it's a missed opportunity
to send a message to that child
that you're the priority
and this is about you,
this is not about me.
I think we've just broken
down the psychology
of what selfies could mean to
us in a situation like that.
And I think that so I'm
not saying across the board
but I'm saying I'm gonna
choose, I'm gonna try to choose
going into events, like a mindset of
doing that, like especially
if it's an enclosed
space where there's lots
of people that could be fans.
- I think the environment is a big deal.
If you're walking down the street--
- Leads to another, leads to another.
- If you're just walking down
the street with your family,
having family time, and
somebody's like hey,
can I get a picture?
That's a 10 second
interaction or whatever.
If they wanna start talking
and they have a bunch
of questions, at that point may be like,
I'm sorry, I'm with my family now.
People are still gonna think
you're a jerk for doing it,
just so you know, 'cause
people are gonna be like,
why can't he just give me a minute?
That's just the way people are.
Like you actually took a
very mature perspective
on the way that you responded
to Sterling K. Brown
and you're only able to do
that because you can relate.
But if somebody couldn't
relate, they would just be like
he's kind of a jerk for doing that.
They wouldn't go to the
next step and be like,
oh that's sweet that he's
doing that for his kid.
Because there's dynamics that people
don't understand going on.
So I do think that the
environment is really important.
If I'm just out in the middle of somewhere
where it's not like all of
a sudden a crowd could form
or somebody else, I'm
gonna say, "Okay sure.
"Let's do a quick photo or whatever."
But I do think that if it's,
amusement parks are the supreme situation
because you're there for your family
to have a good time and one
recognition and one picture
leads to more and then it becomes,
the first time I went to
Disneyland with my kids
right when people were
starting to recognize us,
I ruined their day.
It ruined their day.
- Right.
- 'Cause I was trying
to be nice and I'm like oh,
I'm the approachable guy
from YouTube, yeah of course
you can get a picture with me.
And that turned into I've gotta get a hat.
I've gotta get a hat and sunglasses
and then I always felt
like one of those douches
walking around with a hat
and, I'm wearing a hat
and sunglasses at Disneyland
so you won't recognize me douche.
- Excuse me sir, can I
get a picture with you
because I've never seen
someone so douche-like.
(Rhett chuckles)
Your douche level is so high.
- I ruined my family's day so I do think
that you kinda have to
evaluate the environment
and then you have to have,
I'm sure he said that line,
I'm sorry.
I'm having family time right
now so I'm gonna have to pass.
He's worked on that line.
- Yeah.
- He's made it as
un-disarming as possible.
- Sterling K. disarmament.
That's what I'm gonna
be doing from now on.
Yeah I think that's helpful, I think...
I think that's a good
stopping point, you know.
Food for thought, I think this
has been beneficial for us.
I don't know what it's done for you
but thanks for hanging in there.
- Hopefully it hasn't made
you incredibly nervous
about if you see us in public.
I don't know what to do now
that they've talked about it like this.
Just be yourself, just be yourself.
Be yourself and evaluate the environment.
We'll be doing the same thing.
- Yeah, but it's on us
to set the boundary.
Leave that to us.
We will crush you.
No we won't.
- You have a rec for us?
- Oh yeah, as a reward
for hanging on so long,
give you a recommendation.
♪ Check baby check baby
one, two, three, four ♪
♪ Rec baby rec ♪
You know what, I'd like
to recommend going over
and perusing and maybe participating
in the Good Mythical Morning
and Rhett and Link Reddit threads.
Subreddits.
In the occasional times
that I go through there,
I'm encouraged about
the thoughtful exchanges
that are happening around our content.
So check that out.
And then, if you want more relational
and even deeper interactions with people,
other Mythical Beasts, then of course,
I'll tack on a recommendation
for becoming a member
of the Mythical Society.
But yeah, I'm encouraged by the tone
and the thoughtfulness of
the exchanges on Reddit
and if you haven't been there you might be
pleasantly surprised in
lurking and then joining in.
So those two subreddits.
So there you have it.
- Well thank you for
joining us once again.
We will be doing the same thing.
Just slightly different.
We'll be talking about
something different.
But the same two guys
sitting at the same table
in the same formation.
Link's voice may be a little bit different
because he won't have a cold anymore.
- #EarBiscuits.
Let us know
♪ What your thoughts are ♪
♪ And don't be afraid ♪
♪ To let it shine ♪
♪ If the sun is hidin' ♪
♪ Then your teeth can
make the difference ♪
♪ In someone's life ♪
♪ Just smile a little smile ♪
♪ And brighten the environment ♪
- So that's an original, right?
We don't have to pay anybody for that.
- I think that was painfully obvious, yes.
(Rhett chuckles)
I went to, I was at lunch yesterday.
- Are you done now?
- I'm not done.
- Oh.
- And this one, I could
tell that I got recognized
by someone who was seated with us
and then they were seated further down.
Me and Christy were on a
date and the whole time,
in the back of my mind I
knew that there was this,
these people who recognized
me, they were fans.
It was a little more
like giddy fan energy.
So I've learned to deal
with the fact that like
okay, I know I'm being watched right now
even though I'm on a date.
- Yep.
- It's like,
there was a couple of years
there were it was like
that did a number on me.
But I think I'm over that.
But--
- I thought this was gonna end with,
and I went and sat with them.
- We got a picture afterward.
We ended up leaving at the same time
and they were waiting
outside for me to come out
so at least they didn't
approach me at the table
so I thought that was a nice boundary.
But it was weird 'cause you know,
you ever feel like you're being watched
when you're on a date?
- And it's actually much
easier than people realize
for you to notice that
they've noticed you.
You don't even have to try.
- Even though I'm oblivious.
- Right.
- So thank goodness I'm oblivious.
You notice twice as much as I do.
- I have a great vantage point.
Okay, now we're done.
- [Link] To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.
(electronic music)